[Music]  bells tolling and lights dim Toronto  pays homage to Canada's beloved musician  last night  at the Air Canada Centre the sport loved  by Gord showed love back  [Applause]  meanwhile in the heart of board down his  hometown of Kingston Ontario hundreds  gathered to pay their respects  people of all ages descended on Springer  Market Square makeshift memorials were  started candles lit and of course there  was music  a banner meters long was covered in  messages of condolence and remembrance  [Music]  last August it was the site of another  huge gathering for board a tea in the  hip played their final show  [Applause]  [Music]